contravention roger peyrefitte mise en
question immobilier un marché qui flambe
à paris et en province là messieurs
bonsoir d'abord avant toute chose la
martinique après le passage du cyclone
david nous avons bouleversé le début de
ce journal parce que nous venons de
recevoir il ya quelques secondes des
images vous le verrez assez
impressionnante
au fond si on fait le bilan plus de peur
que de mal puisque le cyclone en toute
dernière minute a fini par dévier sa
route et a touché la martinique mais il
n'a causé que des dégâts matériels il
n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de morts il ya
une trentaine de blessés
les dégâts sont quand même très
important surtout pour les plantations
et pour les installations touristiques
alors je vous laisse voir maintenant
avec un commentaire de laurent broomhead
les dégâts tels que nous les montrent
ces images qui arrivent donc à l'instant
de la martinique porte heureusement
david a dévié au dernier moment vers le
nord
son oeil n'a pas atteint les côtes des
îles françaises le cyclone n'a fait
qu'effleurer la martinique et la
guadeloupe
on peut se demander ce qu'il se serait
passé sans cela car leur bilan et ses
images le prouvent est déjà très lourd
une douzaine de blessés en guadeloupe
une quinzaine en aide
en martinique c'est vrai le pire a donc
été évité grâce entre autres à l'annoncé
de l'arrivée de l'ouragan plusieurs
jours à l'avancé
mais les vents de 120 à 170 km à l'heure
et les pluies torrentielles ont arraché
les toits inondé les maisons détruit la
moitié du réseau électrique coupé
pratiquement toutes les routes
quant aux plantations de bananes de la
guadeloupe et du nord de la martinique
il ne reste que des troncs touchée par
le vent
le bilan sera plus lourd encore à porto
rico où le cyclone a abordé la côte sud
est en fait david s'est comporté dans ce
chapelet d'îles comme une boule lancée
dans un jeu de quilles
ces mouvements désordonnés ont effleuré
les unes touchée plus durement les
autres le cyclone se dirige maintenant
vers les côtes américaines sans qu'on
puisse estimer pour l'instant le danger
et encore je vous le rappelle le cyclone
ne fait qu'effleurer les côtes de la
martinique
à en juger par les conversations de café
de trottoirs et de couloir je crois que
c'est le dossier contraventions qui vous
passionne ce soir un des deux dossiers
est traitée hier en conseil des
ministres le second étant de l'eau a
bien sûr le plus important et mesures de
soutien en matière économique et sociale
je crois que nous les avons amplement
détaillé hier soir revenons donc sur la
sphère des amendes qui elle aussi est
loin de faire l'unanimité
il ne faut pas confondre automobilistes
et chauffeurs disent par exemple les
automobile clubs qui critiquent le
projet de majoration est de paiement
immédiat des amendes pour excès de
vitesse
regardez ce carbone l'enquète de
jean-marc il use
si demain au titre du nouveau projet de
loi certaines mamans les excès de
vitesse par exemple doivent être payés
sur le champ il faudra bien que les
agents de la force publique se chargent
de la perception de ces amendes
une responsabilité qui n'est pas
souhaitée par le principal syndicat de
policiers en tenue
c'est un projet de loi très maladroit et
d'entrer je puis vous dire que la
fédération autonome des syndicats de
police y est hostile et qu'elle
souhaitait dit manquer dans le mond
terre leur poche lorsqu'il viendrait en
discussion devant les assemblées
nous estimons en effet que la police a
actuellement déjà suffisamment des
tâches à remplir sans que l'on d'élise
les policiers et les gendarmes en
percepteurs un cachet au coin du bois
l'autre cacher ou dans la rue pour
rançonner les automobilistes qui sont à
notre avis déjà de bonnes vaches à lait
d'autre part nous craignons qu'il y ait
une sorte d'incompréhension entre
automobilistes et policiers et qu'on
travers de cela on arrive à embarrasser
les tribunaux avec des problèmes
d'outragé à agent de la force publique
par ailleurs nous pensons que le
gouvernement recherche dans cette
opération à faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses de l'état plutôt que de
s'inquiéter véritablement d accident la
circulation routière et dre
semblablement il serait préférable qu'on
a milieu
le réseau routier plutôt que d'en
arriver à de telles extrémités
deuxième problème soulevé par le projet
de loi du ministère d'actrice la menace
d'une amende double au triple en cas de
paiement différé ne risque-t-elle pas
d'aboutir en pratique a totalement
dissuader les automobilistes de faire
appel aux tribunaux et donc de supprimer
toute véritable possibilité de recours
le conducteur pris en est de cette
vitesse est un site est partout
l'ensemble du projet de loi a payé son
amende plutôt qu'à s'adresser aux
tribunaux
enfin je me permets de souligner par un
exemple les conséquences que pourrait
avoir ce projet de loi c'est une
personne qui en fin de mois alors
qu'elle n'a plus d'argent sur son compte
en banque est arrêté pour excès de
vitesse
eh bien elle ne pourra pas verser
immédiatement elle n'a pas de
disponibilité sur elle le montant de
l'amendé et elle sera donc obligé au
moins de payer le double de l'amande
ultérieurement
à moins d'effectuer une contestation
auquel cas elle pourrait être condamnée
à en payer le triple
d'autres mesures envisagées par les
auteurs du projet de loi pourrait rendre
responsable propriétaire à défaut du
conducteur d'un véhicule en infraction
de plus les conditions du retrait du
permis de conduire pourrait être réformé
en l'absence de texte officiel précis
déjà certaines associations d'usagers se
montre réticente touring club de france
et d'augmenter la sécurité des deux
listes cependant dans le projet tel
qu'il est annoncé une part est
inacceptable de faire payer évidemment
doublé de glisse qui n'aura pas eu la
sage précaution d'avoir sur lui son
chéquier d'avoir sur lui sa carte de
crédit ou 500 francs d'ailleurs est ce
vraiment une sage précaution
d'autre part en tant que représentant un
défenseur et deux listes dont une coupe
de france peut craindre en cas de
paiement immédiat de l'amande que les
droits de la défense finalement la
défense de le top 10 des forces de
l'usager ne soit pas véritablement
respecter et c'est très dangereux
enfin en cas de suspension ou de
retraite va me conduire
l'automobiliste était jusqu'ici
défendues par des représentants
d'associations telles que un autre au
sein des commissions de suspension de
permis de conduire
le rôle de ces commissions va-t-il être
amoindrie or on peut se poser la
question mais encore une fois je vous
rappelle il s'agit que d'un projet de
loi qui doit donc passer devant les
députés les sénateurs les uns et les
autres sont en général assez sourcilleux
en matière de libertés individuelles et
la ferme et donc pas entendu alain
peyrefitte le garde des sceaux l'auteur
du projet a voulu pour paul lefèvre
répondre aux reproches qui lui sont déjà
formulées et d'abord cette question
toute simple pourquoi n'arrive-t-on pas
mieux a essayé de recouvrer les amendes
le recouvrement des amendes se fait mal
peut-être parce que les français n'ont
pas l'esprit très civique mais aussi et
sans doute surtout parce que jusqu'à
maintenant le système de recouvrement
des amendes étaient compliquées c'est
pourquoi nous avons imaginé des méthodes
nouvelles qui sont des méthodes rapides
le nouveau texte dit toute intervention
sera interdite y en avait beaucoup
d'interventions en somme faire sauter
les contraventions une expression c'est
vrai étant donné que le processus
administratif était très long et très
lent il y avait des interventions visant
à faire sauter comme on dit les
interventions les contraventions et bien
ces interventions ne seront plus
désormais on en fera partie donc
n'importe quel agent de la force
publique peut devenir un percepteur
oui c'est pas trop et bien c'est pas ça
se fait dans beaucoup de pays pourquoi
ça ne se ferait pas en france on vous
voit mal un agent de police ou même à un
gendarme se promener avec une carte un
appareil d'enregistrement de cartes de
crédit eh bien on le voit la halle en
france parce que ça ne s'est jamais fait
mais pourquoi ça ne se ferait pas ça se
fait dans beaucoup de pays se fait très
régulièrement en angleterre aux états
unis en suède où les cartes de crédit
sont il faut le dire beaucoup plus
développé qu'en france mais pourquoi ça
ne serait pas possible alors le
composteur de cartes de crédit d'un tout
petit appareil et que l'agent
verbalisateur d'avoir avec soi et toute
façon on à nous et à toutes sortes de
moyens de paiement que ce soit les
espèces ou l'échec ce qu'on voudra mais
tout le monde n'a pas
sauf dans son portefeuille de l'argent
liquide cartes de crédit mais limite un
carnet de chèques
en somme si on ne pas payer tout de
suite on sera
pénaliser doublement si on ne peut pas
payer tout de suite on a avantage à ne
pas faire d'excès de vitesse
l'un des éléments
moteur de votre projet c'est au
finalement la fiabilité des cinémomètres
d'appareils qui contrôlent la vitesse
or cette fiabilité a été
depuis quelques temps par les tribunaux
mis un peu en doutent égouttez les
cinémomètres sont considéré généralement
comme ayant une fiabilité à 5 km a l'air
prêt lorsque je peux vous dire c'est que
les instructions qui seront données aux
forces de police
permettront qu'une certaine tolérance en
réalité cette loi n'est pas faite contre
les 20 millions de français qui
conduisent leur voiture
la plupart des français conduisent bien
leur voiture malheureusement il y a des
chauffards c'est pas une loi contre les
français qui conduisent normalement
c'est une loi contre les chauffards qui
sont une infime minorité
mais cette infime minorité suffi à
mettre en danger la vie des autres il y
à chaque année au moins douze mille tués
sur les routes nous sommes le champion
d'europe
pour ce qui est des tués sur les routes
c'est un véritable fléau national
il faut lutter contre ce fléau et lutter
contre ce fléau c'est pas lutter contre
20 millions de producteurs ses protégés
à 20 millions de conducteurs et lutter
contre quelques milliers de chauffeurs
non parce que pour ce qui concerne
l'identité responsabilité du
propriétaire de la voiture dans votre
projet le propriétaire est non seulement
responsable de sa propre conduite
je dirais de la conduite de ceux à qui
il
il traite sa voiture ce n'est pas un
petit peu en contradiction avec le
principe qui dit on punit par la faute
sur la photo qu'on a commises
personnellement celui qui prête sa voix
tu est responsable des agissements de
celui auquel ils la prennent alors s'il
peut le prouver qu'il ne l'a pas prêtées
et qu'elles lui a été volé
elle est empruntée contre son gré le
juge ne manquera pas de considérer que
c'est une circonstance atténuante une
âme un cas de force majeure et que dans
ce cas là le propriétaire n'a pas à
payer la contravention
et s'il ne peut pas fournir cette preuve
il est responsable
bon delà des déclarations d intentions
des uns et des autres nous avons voulu
savoir nous mêmes pourquoi les amendes
étaient si peu payés en france et pour
cela
louis doucet
suivi à sa manière le trajet vous allez
voir d'une contrebasse et sur les
automobilistes messieurs les
contrevenants plus exactement si vous
voulez savoir exactement par où passent
vos contraventions
et bien c'est ici dans cet ordinateur de
la préfecture de police
un ordinateur comme les autres ils sont
n'est pas très spectaculaire mais
monsieur quel cheminement exacte d'une
contravention
à partir d'un contractuel qui met le
collée sur le pare brise tranquille quoi
j'en doute le genre de police
merci
quand même
on a deux volets on a volé qui s'appelle
la carte lettre qui a été posé sur le
pare brise du contretemps
et la carte maîtresse qui est conservé
par le verbalisateur alors parlons ce
lien
celle ci est regroupée dans les
différents organismes de police mme
calicots
commissariat
vers un organisme centralisateur
et finalement est envoyé au cgt
le cje et y étant l'organisme de trets
en lice dans cet endroit
centre de calcul
pour traitement l'ensemble des cartes
lettres de
les cartels
maîtresses bardon qui ont été ainsi
regroupés
sont transcrites sur une pente
magnétique pour permettre le traitement
dans l'anarchie
regroupe également les cartes lettres
que les contrats venant qui ont voulu
payer par timbre leurs contraventions
ont envoyé la pratique trop de pub lice
c'est également transcrit sur une bande
magnétique
et le traitement des contraventions
consiste schématiquement à rassembler
les deux bandes magnétiques voulait
super beau jour on laisse le terreau 0
quelque sorte et en déduire les gens qui
n'ont pas payé
alors avec soleil justice pas en rester
là
on a donc leur numéro de véhicules et
leurs
la marque de leur véhicule à partir du
numéro de véhicules
1h du mat régulation ont fait une
interrogation
du fichier des cartes grises qui ne
donne je trouve aussi dans vos tissus du
mossad dans le dans l'ordinateur vous
raccourcissent et le circuit comme ça on
interroge ce fichier qui nous donne donc
le nom du propriétaire et l'adresse du
propriétaire on est dit alors la liste
des gens qui n'ont pas payé
sous forme d'une liste d'amande pénale
vite cependant voir au trésor pour un
recouvrement dans les finances contre
intervenir le ministère des ptt par
l'intérieur du facteur oui et ensuite
s'il ne paie pas
s'il ne peut pas y aller pour ces
dépenses est classique
alors là c'est du ministère de la
justice vers bien je pense fait qu'à
dernière
et encore le facteur on peut se demander
si la facture
que nuire à réduire aborderont quelque
chose à l'état dans ces conditions moi
je pense que mega man 10 % seulement des
amants payer spontanément après relance
un tiers recouvrait résout donc passé 1
pt
c'est un mystère qui incite certains
automobilistes à tenter leur chance cela
être tout à fait impossible maintenant
on affirme d'ailleurs qu'il ne faut plus
compter sur la moindre des complaisances
pour faire sauter une contravention
ce qui entre parenthèses et reconnaître
implicitement qu'il y avait des
compétences pour couronner cet édifice
le ministre de la justice a décidé que
la ceinture se porterait cette année
même en ville
là je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
remarqué mais la ceinture a une fâcheuse
tendance à passer juste à hauteur du
portefeuille ce qui confirmerait
peut-être ce que j'ai pu lire ce matin
dans un chenal textuellement si cela
continue comme ça à prendre les
automobilistes pour des vaches à lait on
finira par tuer la poule aux oeufs d'or
associons porte son portefeuille à
droite
et puis pour évoquer un sujet proche
sachez que deux français sur trois sont
favorables des mesures draconiennes en
matière d'économie d'énergie c'est ce
que révèle un sondage sofres publié par
l'hebdomadaire le pèlerin les retombées
maintenant du deuxième train de mesures
adopté hier par le gouvernement celle
qui vise à soutenir l'économie et à et
des familles et personnes âgées
des mesures qui ne répondent ni aux
attentes ni à la situation des français
a dit tout à l'heure le parti socialiste
en réponse aux propos en forme de
plaidoyer de raymond barre hier soir à
la télévision
raymond barre qui estimaient qu'il y a
trois ans l'économie française aller à
la dérive et qu'aujourd'hui elle peut
faire face car elle a des atouts
sadi les syndicats veulent maintenant
savoir plus sur les intentions du
premier ministre l'invitation qui leur a
lancé n'a pas été trop mal accueillie
mais on reste souvent attentiste chez
les syndicats d'ores et déjà la fen et
les pme ont dit oui à raymond barre
voilà donc pour un traitement disons
classique de l'information sous la vie
ce soir la rédaction d'antenne 2 a voulu
s'attaquer à un dossier qui lui paraît
choquant la flambée des prix dans
l'immobilier
on connaissait le phénomène engendré par
la libération des loyers cigref
maintenant la hausse record du prix à
l'achat d'un appartement pour vous et
pour moi alors aussitôt
nos reporters ont voulu enquêter à chaud
alors voici d'abord un exemple tourner
ce matin par jean jacques dufour en
région parisienne
nous sommes ici sur un chantier dans le
xviiie arrondissement les prix des
appartements situés dans cet immeuble la
environ 7000 à 8000 francs le mètre
carré dans des quartiers plus chics
comme le septième ou huitième
arrondissement le prix du mètre carré
atteint parfois 25 mille ans c'est
beaucoup c'est énorme
en clair ça signifie que pour le prix
d'une r5 vous avez à peine des toilettes
mais sachez que cette année le prix
moyen du mètre carré est d'environ 8000
700 francs contre 7800 francs l'année
dernière s'impliquent une augmentation
énorme plus d'un virus 20% virgule trois
par mois
ça n'a pas empêché pourtant le marché
d'immobilier de se comporter de façon
exceptionnelle pendant le mois d'août
d'un côté les français économise pendant
leurs vacances de l'autre ils se ruent
sur des appartements assez cher comment
expliquez-vous cet engouement
vous avez deux causes essentielles à
l'heure actuelle dans le domaine
immobilier la première avec les
primordial c'est le manque d'ouverture
de chantier nous nous trouvons à l'heure
actuelle avec un stock maximum de six à
sept mois pour paris est la deuxième
cause c'est l'inflation
je pense que les français qui devaient
acheter un appartement aux alentours de
1981 préfère l'acheter
aujourd'hui sachant qu'entre 80 et ne
trouveront pas un prix moyen au mètre
carré dans paris à moins de dix mille
francs
et c'est là la cause essentielle de
l'engouement pour l'immobilier à l'heure
actuelle dans passe oui dans notre souci
nous intéresser beaucoup à ce qui se
passe en province nous avons aussi
compléter cette enquête par un point
similaire effectué par philippe sassier
à bordeaux et vous allez voir d'abord à
lyon
l'organe de monsieur carreaux bonjour
merci d'être avec nous alors est ce que
les lyonnais ont acheté plus
d'appartements cette année que les
autres années et bien la tendance la
bonne tendance que nous avions remarqué
au premier trimestre de cette année
c'est largement confirmée au cours du
deuxième trimestre et au cours d'une des
mois de juillet et d'août
si bien que l'on peut dire sans que s'il
n'y a pas eu un boom extraordinaire
il ya eu quand même une activité
immobilière extrêmement soutenu et c'est
vrai dans l'est
et c'est vrai dans toute la région rhône
alpes c'est vrai semble-t-il à peu près
dans toute la région rhône alpes si nous
avons bien vendu nous sommes un peu
moins optimiste pour l'avenir
quand on compare les chiffres suivants
on sait que au cours de deuxième
trimestre 79 il y a eu dans la région de
lyon
130 mises en chantier alors que il s'est
vendu 800 logements environ
je pense que la comparaison entre les
deux chiffres est très instructive je
trouve qu'on ne trouve pas de terrain
dans le centre des villes bien qu'il y
ait une forte demande
cela est dû à plusieurs raisons
notamment par exemple des raisons tenant
administrative tenant au plafond légal
de densité par exemple monsieur k rhône
merci nous allons maintenant aller à
bordeaux nous allons rencontrer monsieur
subercazes alors première question est
ce que il se passe dans la région de
bordeaux
le même phénomène est ce que les
bordelais reviennent dans le centre de
la ville et bien tout d'abord je crois
qu'il faut faire en ce qui concerne
bordeaux une première constatation
bordeaux sur le plan du marché
immobilier est un marché calme sans
à-coups où rien ne va très bien et où
rien ne va non plus très mal je crois
que en ce qui concerne la tendance du
deuxième trimestre 1979 il y a eu
effectivement une légère augmentation en
volume global des ventes et je pense que
nous aurons une certitude à la faim et à
l'examen des comptes du deuxième
semestre mais à l'heure actuelle on peut
dire que surtout en aquitaine ce qui a
motivé les mois de juillet août sur les
ventes de l'immobilier se sont surtout
passer sur les côtes atlantiques et donc
dans la résidence de loisirs bien
philippe sassier ça c'est l' enquête
maintenant les conclusions alors
pourquoi ça grimpe sa g civic si fort
dans l'immobilier il se rappelle un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé en 1974
juste après le choc pétrolier une ruée
vers l'immobilier d'où est vers la
pierre parce que vers les français font
confiance à la pierre pour se protéger
de l'inflation hors aujourd'hui si
l'immobilier monde sait que
on achète beaucoup et cette augmentation
des prix de l'immobilier est plus rapide
que l'augmentation du coût de la vie de
façon générale c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que il ya un
retour ça joue pas c'est très important
comme phénomène noté vers le centre des
villes les budgets sont plus serrés 11
du coût du transport
11 du coût de l'essence est aujourd'hui
ont d'abord note parfois un petit peu sa
résidence à maisons individuelles pour
un appartement au centre des vues
troisièmement il ya une augmentation
assez forte qui va pour prendre le vent
se poursuivre du coût d'un crédit du
coût d'un emprunt pourquoi parce que
plusieurs pays dont la france ont obligé
de pratiquer une politique d'argent cher
afin de défendre leur monnaie et de
rémunérer les capitaux hors cette
critique d'art jonchère conduit à faire
monter le coût du crédit et beaucoup de
gens semble-t-il essaie d'anticiper lés
futures hausses bon les français
seraient punis dans la pierre mais aussi
dans l'ordre
oui vous savez que les français
détiennent 4600 tonnes d'or autant que
tout plus que tous les européens réunis
ici aujourd'hui
effectivement on continue pour avoir les
mêmes raisons rp l'immobilier à chercher
un refuge contre l'inflation contre les
inquiétudes du moment
en achetant des napoléon et des autres
alors tout cela avec le français était
aux rives et ils ont tendance à un peu
moins épargnés alors il ya eu là un
phénomène qui est assez intéressant à
noter pendant les six premiers mois de
l'année les dépôts non et caisse
d'epargne ont été très forts fait sa
force ans de plus que l'an passé à la
même époque et puissant le tigre coup de
frein très nette en juillet et en août
il est donc très intéressant sera très
intéressant de savoir quel sera le
comportement des français jauzion à
thésauriser ce qui pénalise l'industrie
et un espace vraiment très intéressant
de savoir ce que vont faire les français
pendant les trois mois qui viennent
alors que ce soir ce que nous pouvions
dire sur cette flambée finalement assez
peu justifier des prix dans l'immobilier
un mot encore sur les problèmes français
avec d'abord cette déclaration de
christian bilhac aujourd'hui à saint pol
de léon et qui permet aux établissements
scolaires du second cycle de pouvoir
poursuivre les expériences de journée
continue
les expulsions dans les foyers de la
sonacotra foyer de travailleurs immigrés
bien strasbourg comme en région parisien
souvent les incidents et des
protestations mais quand même un accord
a bondi dans la seine saint denis entre
les résidents et la direction du foyer
et puis ce commentaire de laurent fabius
la suite du oui des communistes à une
rencontre avec le ps c'est un élément
très important pour des blocs
le climat politique en france a dit le
porte parole socialiste ce matin sur
europe les affaires du monde maintenant
avec tout d'abord bien sûr l'évolution
de la situation en irlande déjà deux
arrestations
trois jours après l'assassinât de lord
mountbatten deux suspects arrêtés qui
ont été inculpées cet après midi
et puis un contre coup cette fois en
irlande 2 en irlande là la presse c'est
d'une manière générale l'opinion
irlandais c'est à dire l'opinion dublin
ont reproché au premier ministre à pine
sa passivité dans cette affaire c'est
par exemple que monsieur lynch n'avait
pas interrompu tout de suite ses
vacances au portugal
ja pinch accepter tout à l'heure de
rencontrer l'âme soeur dans les jours
qui viennent c'est ici au tribunal de
l'ue blain la capitale d'irlande du sud
que deux jeunes irlandais de 25 ans ont
été inculpés moins de trois jours après
l'attentât contre lord mountbatten il
avait été arrêté une heure avant
l'explosion du bateau il circulait à
bord d'une voiture volée et transportait
des explosifs
ainsi prend fin la polémique engagée par
la presse britannique qui accusait
l'irlande du sud de laisser agir l'ira
l'armée républicaine irlandaise sur son
territoire et pour bien montrer que
l'irlande du sud participaient au deuil
des britanniques
le président de la république monsieur
villery assisté à la cérémonie de
rapatriement des corps des victimes de
l'attentât
trois cercueils ont été monté dans un
avion pour londres
celui de nantes betten dont les
funérailles auront lieu mercredi
prochain de sa belle mère et de son
petit fils pendant ce temps l'irlande du
nord vit dans la crainte des
représailles
la tension monte entre armées
britanniques catholiques et protestants
pour les catholiques comme ici dans ce
bastion républicain de paul road
c'est le début d'une nouvelle offensive
de lire depuis avril dernier
les commandos de ligue races sont
réorganisés sont restructurées et
surtout se sont dotés d'un armement
nouveau beaucoup plus sophistiqué quant
à l'armée britannique
elle n'avait jamais subi en une seule
attaque de paris pert elle sait que ses
adversaires ont gagné en puissance de
feu et en soutien populaire
elle sait aussi qu à moins d'instaurer
la loi martiale et de tirer
littéralement sur tout ce qui paraît
suspect elle ne peut pas vaincre
militairement l'iran
les protestants enfin sont en train de
se réarmer
car dit-il si les militaires ont les
mains liées par les politiciens nous
nous saurons comment éliminer
physiquement les terroristes
la guerre dure depuis 10 ans déjà m'a
dit une vieille habitante de falls road
et il se pourrait que le pire soit à
venir pays basque espagnol encore un
attentat il a coûté la vie à un policier
c'est la centième victimes du terrorisme
depuis le début de l'année il rend un
couple exécuté aujourd'hui au nord de
téhéran il était accusée d'adultère et
puis le dernier jour la fin de la visite
de georges marchais en algérie le
président chadli vous le voyez a reçu le
numéro un communiste tout à l'heure à
alger georges marchais qui demande
maintenant au gouvernement français de
reconnaître le polisario c'est
maintenant la suite de notre tour de
france de la saison touristique ce soir
nous allons aller en bretagne une région
magnifique qui malheureusement bien que
sans marée noire n'a pas encore attiré
beaucoup de touristes cette année
regardez l'exemple choisi par dominique
torrès et michel alik of roscoff l'une
des cités les plus touchés l'an dernier
et qui pourtant était beaucoup d'efforts
pour cette saison
ce petit port des huées qui aurait selon
les historiens quelques six millions
d'années accueille aujourd'hui des
bateaux de plaisance des curistes et les
touristes tous azimuts cité tranquille
aux 4000 habitants la population de
roscoff et qu'elles soient plus
nombreuses l'été et on y parle autant
l'anglais et l'allemand que le français
pourtant il ya deux ans souvenez vous
c'était la désolation avec l'amoco cadiz
et ses vagues noires où tous enlisé et
mouret qui aurait pensé alors que
roscoff et ses voisins du littoral
breton pourrait si vite oubliées
la marée noire n'a pas laissé grand
traces dans la région actuellement on
peut le dire il ya toutefois un point
alarmant pour nous responsables du
tourisme c'est que la désaffection des
allemands de la clientèle allemande
or la clientèle allemande est très
intéressante à deux points de vue tout
d'abord vous savez fort bien que c'est
une clientèle qui dépensent beaucoup
étant donné la valeur d'une marque et
d'autre part c'est une clientèle fidèle
il y a deux raisons majeures je pense à
cette désaffection c'est d'une part que
la presse allemande sans vouloir faire
le procès de personne mais la presse
allemande annonce que la bretagne est
toujours dans le mazout et les tours
opérateurs quant à eux ont éliminé notre
région de leurs circuits touristiques
pour quelques années
partout en bretagne on vit du tourisme
et partout cette année on s'en plaint
l'opération joie en bretagne a été un
échec malgré 40 % de réduction à la sncf
en juillet les touristes étrangers ont
afflué de dinars à rennes en passant par
au score tandis que les touristes
français persistait à bouder la bretagne
en août la foule est dense certes mais
paraît-il bien trop économe j'ai
consulté quelques commerces locaux
le chiffre d'affaires a baissé de 10 %
de juillet 79 à juillet 78 qui pourtant
été une mauvaise année et pour les
raisons que vous savez et par contre
depuis le début du mois d'août on sent
une légère augmentation de 5 à 10%
les gens viennent mais
non pas n'ont pas l'impression qu'ils
aient de l'argent à dépenser ou du moins
pas pour le loisir ils ont restreint le
budget du loisir c'est toujours toujours
rempli mais toujours les petits menus
les boissons trêve eu beaucoup de
carafes d'eau cette année en bretagne on
n'a pas le coeur à jouer les émirs même
le temps des vacances et congés payés se
paye cher et les touristes ne font que
passer à la recherche d'un soleil que
clément alors chaque région se cherche
un tourisme fidèles un tourisme de béton
à roscoff on mise désormais à fond sur
les curistes sur ces vieilles dames en
dentelle qui reviennent bon gré mal gré
chaque année sous les parasols à tarbes
edouard lahore libre après 48 heures de
garde à vue il a quitté aujourd'hui sans
inculpation les locaux de la gendarmerie
aux etats unis la centrale nucléaire de
three mile island fait à nouveau parler
d'elle hier six ouvriers cette centrale
ont été irradiés alors qu'il réparait
une soupape dans l'unité de traitement
d'autres combustibles
passons maintenant à la météo avec vous
laurent brault maître d'alors salaire de
se gâter un petit peu après un temps
très très beau nom mais le temps va
rester globalement beau grâce pendant
tout le week-end grâce à l'anticyclone
qui au dessus de l'europe nous amène de
l'air venant du sud-ouest de l'air chaud
mais de l'air également humide c'est
vrai c'est pourquoi il y aura une
tendance orageuse la carte pour demain
et bien du soleil et pourquoi partout et
des éthers si dominante mais sur l'est
c'est vrai des passages nuageux plus
nombreux avec quelques averses éparses à
caractère orageux sur l'ouest au
contraire c'est le soleil qui devrait
dominer avec simplement quelques
passages nuageux samedi bien le même
temps continue je tenais à me déplacer
le symbole les orages encore plus vers
l'est
il n'aura également dans le nord-est car
ailleurs il devrait faire beau toujours
avec simplement quelques brouillards et
brumeux le matin et des nuages bas un
peu plus nombreux près des côtes de la
manche comme tout le week-end s'annonce
bien bien voici maintenant les résultats
du tiercé qui se disputait aujourd'hui à
vincennes dans le prix de vendée fait
assez exceptionnel il ya eu une arrivée
eco pour la seconde place qui nous
donnons deux combinaisons gagnantes le
neuf
las le 14 et puis vous voyez le 9 14
hélas cette combinaison apporte dans
l'ordre 8181 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent
toujours pour 5 francs 2157 francs 50
porcs tennis dans l'open des états unis
qui se dispute à flushing meadows le
premier tour a vu le défaite surprise de
l'italien panatta et du mexicain ramires
tous deux têtes de série quant à ken
bord que vous voyez ici il n'a eu aucun
problème face à la maca mitchell qui l'a
battu en trois sets 6 1 6 1 6 2
l'enjeu est important pour le champion
suédois quand on sait qu'il n'a jamais
gagné les internationaux des états unis
d'ailleurs c'est le seul tournoi
d'importance que borg n'a pas encore
remporté et de plus s'il gagne cette
année ce sera pour lui le grand chelem
voilà je vous fixe maintenant les
rendez-vous avec l'information tout
d'abord vers 23h30 bernard pradines haut
pour le dernier journal
et puis demain à 12h45 daniel bilalian
pour antenne de midi ce journal est
terminée bonsoir à tous à demain
à